nothing could be more analog than
parcels and letters but this week their
movement was halted by a very modern
disruption
Royal Mail sorting offices were struck
by a Cyber attack which left it unable
to dispatch letters and Parcels overseas
it all happened like a scene in a film
according to reports the printers and
the Royal Mail sorting office suddenly
started spewing out messages from the
lockbit ransomware gang saying your data
are stolen and encrypted and demanding
payment to sort the situation out
dramatic
simple and horribly effective and only
if the victim wondering
what on Earth do I do now
it's the question Kieran Martin formerly
head of the national cyber security
center now in Oxford Don he's been asked
many times
so
should you pay the government advisers
know I would advise no but plenty of
people do
what I would encourage people to think
about as well as the ethics and morality
of paying
is sometimes practically it doesn't make
sense to pay ransomware gangs like
logbit use a virus to scramble the files
on your computers and send you a message
demanding a ransom for unscrambling them
log bit victims number well over 1000
including the Automotive Group
Continental British company Kingfisher
Insurance rail operator merseyrail and
consultancy firm Accenture
like many ransomware gangs not bit has
ties to Russia although experts play
down the possibility of a nation-state
attack
more likely it's just the latest example
of a criminal Boom the guardian was hit
by a ransomware attack this month just
one of thousands every year
that doesn't cut it with frustrated
Royal Mail customers like Andrew Pope
this is the last now in the coffin for
me I've already transferred my UK
business away from Royal Mail to the
other providers I didn't want to but I
had to and now the international
business that I have which is about a
fifth of the business I'll also transfer
away from Royal Mail Royal Mail declined
to comment on the incident but it still
hasn't resolved the problem and the
backlog of parcels is already over half
a million
closing the door on this incident it
takes some doing
Roland Menthol Sky News